BOTH EX-EDMONTON JONATHAN TOEWSE
HAWKS TO AN UPDATE.
CENTRING PASS.
UMP
UP IN THE PLAY.. 30-11 THEY
WERE OUT-SHOT.
EARLY ON THEY'RE GETTING PUCKS
TO THE NET   AFTER SIX CONSECUTE
LOSSES OVER THE YEARS.
THEY DROPPED 12 OF 13 AEN SHOT.
REBOUND KANE.
SAVE SKINNER.
ANDUGHT OFF.
LANKINEN, AND A GOOD BLOCK RIGHT
THERE THAT GOES RIGHT TON THE D.
ONE-TIMER!ON.IN
BARRIE SCORES HIS FIRST!
3-0 GLOVE OF
LANKINEN.
JUST A REAL GOOD SLAPPER, HE THL
HOCKEY LEAGUE.
McLEOD.ONTON RUNNING CHICAGO
HE PICKS HIS PUCK OFFFAVE SOME N
QUITE A BIT AND
CREDITED FOR THE CHICAGO GOAL ON
A DOUBLE REDIRECT.
HE PICKEKE POST! JACK.
MAYBE O
WRIST SHOT.
SAVE!
AND FOEGEL KASSIAN.
DISHES OFF.
FOEGELE ITING.
ONE-TIMER.
WHAT A SAVE, LAC ANYONE  ON THIE
BY LANKINEN.
>> Jack:OD.
EDMONTON LEADING 4-1.
LOOKING TO CLOSE IT OUT AND
IM DeBRINCAT.
HAS THE ONLYERE'S A CHANCE.
HE SET IT IN MOTION TO SEE HIM .
NOW HE HAS A STEP ON PULJUJARVI.
HE'S IN.
DENIED BY SKINR A SECOND TIME G!
DeBRINCAT'S SECOND SLICES THE
DEFICIT TO 4-2.GET TO DeBRINCATE
AND THE SNIPER PUTS IT 18th.
5-2 EDMONTON. GETS IT, FUNNELS
IT, BANG, BAR   MADE, RAIKKONEN.
HE -- LANKININ